Steve: Buenos días María.
Maria: Buenos días Steve,
muchas gracias por invitarme.
Steve: De nada.
Es mi placer poder discutir
contigo sobre el español,
que es un idioma que mucha
gente aprende en el mundo.
Quiero hablar sobre las dificultades y
facilidades del aprendizaje de idiomas.
María tiene su canal.
Voy a dejar un enlace @espanolconmaria
Maria: ¡Así es!
La forma tropical de aprender Español
Steve: La forma tropical.
Bueno porque tu eres nativa de Colombia.
Maria: Sí, señor.
Steve: Y tú enseñas el español
a través del internet hace años?
M: Sí, señor.
Hace ya más de cinco años.
S: Cinco años...
Y la mayoría de tus seguidores
son gente que habla inglés.
M: Sí, bueno no es la mayoria...
Pero, digamos que, el primer país
que me sigue es Estados Unidos.
Pero yo creo que si sumamos los demás,
no me atrevo a decir que sean la mayoría.
Pero del país que más me
siguen es de Estados Unidos.
Steve: Pero de otros países,
como por ejemplo, ¿Qué países?
M: Mucha gente de Brasil, bastante
gente de Canadá, Marruecos.
S: Angloparlantes o franceses.
M: Pueden ser franco y angloparlantes.
Mucha gente de Bélgica.
S: Ah, de Bélgica.
M: Y curiosamente también gente de España.
Pero creo que son muchos
extranjeros, que viven en España.
Steve: Y desde el punto de vista
de angloparlantes,
hay ciertas dificultades del
español que, por ejemplo,
un brasileño no va a considerar dificultad
porque los idiomas son muy parecidos.
Pero yo creo que tú tienes una
idea de cuáles son los problemas.
Porque siempre se dice
que el español es fácil.
Que es el idioma más fácil porque
se escribe como se pronuncia
Y otras cosas...
Y hay muchas palabras también en español
que son parecidas a palabras en inglés.
¿Cuáles son las dificultades o los errores
que cometen los angloparlantes
que aprenden el español?
M: Bueno, a nivel gramatical, pues
me gustaría dividirlo en categorías.
Podemos dividirlo en gramática,
en pronunciación y en vocabulario.
En gramática, creo que el error más común
y que incluso personas con un
nivel avanzado siguen cometiendo,
tiene que ver con la sintaxis.
Y específicamente con las negaciones.
En español, la negación tiene que ir
antes del verbo.
Por ejemplo: "No quiero estudiar".
Pero el angloparlante suele
decir "Quiero no estudiar".
S: (Risas) Interesante, si.
M: Suele decir
"Quiero no ir", "Quiero no estar".
En vez de "No quiero estar", "No quiero ir"
Entonces es esa parte.
Y de hecho, vas a encontrar tambien
Hispanohablantes nativos
que invierten ese orden.
Y yo creo que tiene que ver también
con la influencia del inglés en su cultura.
Específicamente, las personas de
Puerto Rico y República Dominicana.
Escuchaba muchos, por ejemplo,
hacer la pregunta "¿Qué tu quieres?"
Que es el mismo orden de "What do you want"
Pero digamos, lo estrictamente
correcto sería ¿Tú qué quieres?
S: Pero este es un punto muy interesante.
Porque en español puedes
decir simplemente "¿Qué quieres?"
M: Ajá. Puedes decir "Qué quieres?"
S: Yo he visto un tipo que
empezaba a aprender español.
Y el hecho de que en el español, el
pronombre personal no es necesario,
es algo extraño para
alguien que habla Inglés.
Porque por ejemplo "Aprenderás"
"You will take" en inglés.
Necesita el "to you".
¿Cómo te llamas?
en francés digamos
"¿Comment tu t'apelles?"
Entonces en español,
el hecho de que el pronombre
personal normalmente no se usa
es una cosa que al principio
es un poco díficil.
Para mi...Me parece.
M: Es que creo que la conjugación...
El verbo en español es
el corazón de la oración.
Y el verbo tiene mucha informacion,
porque te dice cuál es la acción.
Pero cómo lo conjugas,
te dice quién la hizo.
Entonces ahí puedes
omitir el pronombre.
Por ejemplo, el verbo
"Querer" "Quieres, tú quieres"
Ya no necesitas decir el tú antes
Te dice el tiempo y el modo verbal.
Y además, puede tener los pronombres
de complemento dentro de la misma palabra.
Por ejemplo "Quiéreme"
Tu-quiere-a-mi, en una órden.
Tú quiéreme.
S: Sí, pero no.
Yo quería decir, por ejemplo en
Inglés "I go, You go, We go, They go"
M: Y sólo sería "Vamos" "Van"
S: Entonces necesitan el pronombre personal
Si no, no vas a saber "¿Quién va?"
Y también en Francés
"Je vais, tu vas, il va"
Y entonces necesitas el pronombre personal.
Pero en español, es evidente
del verbo mismo, de quién se trata.
M: Si, es el sujeto tácito.
S: Es una cosa que para mí es...
Y nosotros tenemos costumbres de
nuestros idiomas nativos, que continuán.
Y la gente hablando español, continuá
utilizando el pronombre personal,
aunque no sea necesario en el español.
M: Aunque sí lo usan,
puede que no suene tan fluído
pero no necesariamente sea un error.
S: Sí, evidentemente.
Pero para comprender, si tú no
te das cuenta y eres principiante...
¿Cómo te llamas?
"Tú" ¿Como -tú- te llamas?
¿Por qué no hay tú?
Puede ser una dificultad
pequeña, pero no importa.
Otros errores...
M: Otro, con eso mismo que acabas de decir
de cosas que son típicas del idioma y que replicas
es que en inglés, no siempre necesitas
poner un artículo antes del sustantivo
pero en español sí.
Realmente son excepciones
en las que no los ponés.
Entonces, por ejemplo
"Llegué a la casa" "Compré la comida"
En inglés tú dirias "I bought food".
No "I bought the food".
Entonces, ese es el error invertido que
cometemos los latinos, cuando hablamos Inglés
Que le ponemos "The" a todo antes.
S: Sí, es la cuestión del artículo.
Hay muchos idiomas
donde no existen artículos.
En Japonés, Ruso y otros...
y ellos, hablantes de esos idiomas, tienen
mucha dificultad en la utilización de
artículos.
Siempre tenemos las virtudes
de nuestro idioma nativo.
M: Así es.
Yo siempre les digo "Es mejor
que siempre pongan el artículo
y aprendan las exepciones,
a que no lo pongan y luego..."
S: Interesante, si.
M: A nivel gramatical.
Justo antes de que estuviéramos grabando,
hablábamos de que todo el mundo
habla del -ser y estar- o -por y para-
Pero hay otra cosa que
también es muy común
y que a veces olvidamos
como hacerle énfasis.
Y es en los verbos que exigen preposiciones
Por ejemplo, "Ir -a- la fiesta"
no solo es "ir fiesta"
Y como ese verbo hay muchos, que
tienen un complemento de régimen,
y necesitan la preposición.
Por ejemplo me acordé
"de ti" o me acordé "de eso".
Y ese "de", esas preposiciones,
casi siempre las olvidan.
Porque en su lengua materna,
ese verbo no necesita la preposición.
Entonces, " I remember you" Yo-acordé-ti.
No, "Me acuerdo de ti".
S: Sí, pues aún en inglés
hay contradicciones.
Por ejemplo,"I listen to you" "I hear you"
Es por eso, que como en ejemplos
de LingQ, tienes que fijarte las frases.
Porque asi te puedes acordar de las frases.
Y así los artículos serían
incluidos en esta expresión.
M: Y sobre todo también...
1) Eso 2) Hacer la escucha
y la lectura muy consciente.
O sea, no solo leer y entender la idea.
Sino de verdad, fijarse muy bien
cuál es la estructura de cada verbo.
Obviamente te entendemos si cometes el error.
No es un tema de comprensión.
Aqui es más un tema de satisfacción
de querer hablar correctamente.
Pero si tu me dices "Acuerdo ti", pues
obviemente también entiendo, ¿no?
Steve: Si.
Pero también para mi por ejemplo "Visitar".
"Visitar a México" "Visitar México"
En inglés es "Visitar México"
Pero en español no.
Maria: Si es un lugar, tú puedes
decir "Voy a visitar México"
Pero si es a una persona,
necesitas el voy a visitar "A" Steve.
Steve: Bueno, yo no sabia esto.
Pero en portugues es siempre con "a"...
Yo no sé.
Bueno, okey.
Puedes visitar un país sin "a".
Pero si vas a visitar a una persona...
Maria: Es con "A"
Steve: necesitas el "A"
Maria: De hecho mira, aquí tenia que
con lo de la preposición vamos a seguir.
Recordar " a " una persona.
Tenia como mucho recalcado,
que era un error super común.
Vamos a aprovechar-nos- de alguien.
Ah, bueno esto era otra cosa.
Los reflexivos que cambian el sentido
cuando, digamos, el verbo el que cambia el sentido
si se vuelve reflexivo.
Por ejemplo, "Aprovechar o aprovecharse".
O "parar y pararse".
que parar es "To stop" y
pararse es "To stand up"
Esos también son verbos que
confunden mucho a los angloparlantes.
Steve: Otra vez...
Maria: Parar = "To stop" ¡Para, para!
Pero si yo te digo
"Párate" es "Stand up"
Steve: Ah bueno, yo no sabia.
Maria: es como "Levántate"
Levántate es lo mismo que párate.
Entoncés hay muchos verbos
que podemos conocer el verbo,
pero cuando lo volvemos
reflexivo, su significado cambia.
Steve: Pero todas esas reglas, creo
que pueden ser muchas, muchísimas.
Y siempre es una cuestion de escuchar
mucho, leer mucho para acostumbrarse.
Porque no se puede recordar todas esas reglas.
Maria: Es imposible.
Yo creo que lo que tú dices
de "Comprehensible Input"
pero no se como decirlo en español,
como traducirlo correctamente.
Tener estimulos de adquisición
de lenguaje es clave para eso.
S: Y puede ser tambien que este
idioma, por ejemplo el Español,
en El Caribe, en Puerto Rico
pueda ser una manera de
hablar que para ti es un error,
pero para ellos es la manera
en la que usan el idioma.
M: Valida.
S: Entoncés puede ser que hay formas
del Español en Argentina, en Chile,
en Colombia, en Puerto Rico...
que hay costumbres diferentes en la manera
de utilizar el idioma
M: Te voy a contar algo curioso...
Una vez, yo no me acuerdo donde estaba
pero habia una persona de Puerto
Rico y me dijo "Llámame pa´ tra"
Y yo le dije ¿Qué?
"Si, llámame pa tra"
"Call me back" aparte en
vez de decir atrás dicen "tra".
En vez de "Devuélveme la llamada"
que es lo que diríamos en Colombia,
dicen "Llámame para atrás" y
lo pronuncian llámame pa´ tra.
y es de "Call me back" porque
traducen literalmente las expresiones.
S: Hay ejemplos como
esos en Quebec también.
En el Francés.
Hay cierta influencia del inglés en el
francés, que se habla en Quebec también.
Pero bueno, si tu vives en
Puerto Rico o en Quebec,
tienes que adaptarte a la manera en que
la gente utiliza el idioma en este lugar.
Si estas con amigos o trabajando tienes
que hablar como ellos, más o menos.
M: Asi es.
Steve: Aún si no quieres.
Al final vas a hablar como
la gente alrededor de ti.
M: Mi mamá cuando era
pequeña siempre me decia,
"A dónde fueres, haz lo que vieres"
Basicamente, adáptate a
las costumbres de cada lugar
e incluye tambien dentro
de eso, la forma de hablar.
Steve: Si.
Bueno, al final podemos decir que
una cosa muy atractiva del español,
es la variedad de paises, del
idioma mismo, de las culturas
de la gente que habla en español.
Esto hace que el español sea un
idioma que vale la pena aprender.
Hay tantos paises que utilizan este idioma,
que tiene una historia y una cultura muy rica
Pero tiene culturas e
historias distintas en cada país.
M: ¿Sabes también qué
me parece que facilita?
Relacionado con eso de la cultura...
Es que además hay mucho
contenido para practicar español.
Porque como estan tantas culturas,
entonces tienes libros de cada país,
peliculas de cada país, canciones de cada país.
Entoncés hace que sea fácil
encontrar el material para practicarlo.
S: Tantas telenovelas de
Colombia, por ejemplo.
M: Muchas.
Steve: Muchas, muy muy buenas.
Okey, muchas gracias María.
Maria: Con mucho gusto.
Steve: Yo espero que muchos de
mis oyentes vayan a visitar tu canal...
¿O visitar tú canal? o ¿A tú canal?
M: Visitar tú canal.
S: Para aprender o
mejorar su nivel de español.
M: Muchas gracias.
Los invito allá para contarles también
los errores de pronunciación y vocabulario típicos.
S: Ok, muchas gracias.
M: Muchas gracias, Steve.